DAN SOUZA: Pesto is a simple,
versatile sauce that's
easy to make in a food processor.
But many home cooks
who try and make it are
frustrated when their
bright green sauce quickly
turns black, like this pesto here.
Why does basil darken this way?
Well, when basil is cut, oxygen
mixes with chemical compounds
called polyphenols, which are on
the surface cells of the leaf.
This reaction causes the dark
color and bruised appearance.
The more you chop the
basal, the more polyphenols
you are exposing to the oxygen,
and the darker it will get.
And this is why pesto
can turn almost black.
However, basil is so prone
to this enzymatic reaction
that even folding or
rolling the leaves can
break enough vascular tissue and
fibers on the surface of the leaves
to cause discoloration.
And I've got two leaves
here to show the point.
This leaf here was folded
up, kind of rolled up a bit.
And this one was not.
As you can see, there's
lots of dark lines
where that oxidation
has already taken place.
Enzymes are biological agents that
increase the rate of chemical change,
and not just in basil.
Unlike many foods with strong
flavors, garlic and onion
have almost no aroma in this state.
No one cries when they're
shopping for an onion.
But slice into that onion, and
the aroma can be overpowering.
That's when the tears can flow.
So what's happening?
An enzymatic reaction, similar
to the process that causes
sliced basil to darken.
Before slicing, enzymes
and amino acids are
stored in separate sections of
the garlic and onion's cells.
When the cell walls are ruptured by
a knife, the enzymes and amino acids
react with each other
to create new compounds.
These compounds are responsible
for the characteristic flavor
of garlic and onions.
In garlic, odorless sulfur-containing
amino acids come into contact
with an enzyme called alliinase.
The reaction of the
two eventually produces
a new compound called allicin,
which is responsible for garlic's
familiar scent and flavor.
The more the garlic is broken
down, the more flavor you get.
So for example, minced garlic, or garlic
pressed through a mincer like this,
is going to have a lot more
flavor than a piece of garlic
that I just slice very thin.
In this garlic, I'm breaking
a lot of those cells
and I'm allowing a lot of
that reaction to take place.
Here, I'm doing much
less cellular damage.
So in onion, the process is
the same, but the compounds
created are called thiosulfinates.
Unlike garlic, onions
also contain an enzyme
called LF synthase, which is responsible
for producing the tear-causing compound
propanethial-S-oxide.
In the test kitchen, we've tried more
than a dozen purported home recipes
for keeping tears at bay,
everything from freezing onions
to lighting a match
while we're slicing them.
But the best solution is
to wear contact lenses,
or don a pair of ski or swim goggles.
What you need is a physical
barrier to protect your eye.
If you don't wear contact lenses,
your best bet is a pair of goggles.
Looks a little bit funny, but it works.
Also, using a sharp knife
with a really good edge
will inflict less cellular
damage and can actually
limit production of
propanethial-S-oxide,
so you want to make sure
your knife is sharp.
So we understand how
enzymatic reactions start.
But what about stopping them?
One way to halt the enzymatic reactions
is with the application of heat.
Heat deactivates enzymes,
while at the same time
transforms these potent flavor and aroma
compounds into more pleasant forms.
This is what happens when you
cook sliced garlic and onions.
You can also add another
ingredient to stop the reaction.
In the test kitchen, we ran a
simple test with minced garlic
for a basic vinaigrette,
with three parts olive oil
and one part lemon juice.
In one batch, we added one
teaspoon of minced garlic
immediately to the dressing.
That's this batch here.
In a second batch, we soak the minced
garlic in lemon juice for 10 minutes.
Then we made the dressing with
the garlic and lemon juice.
Finally, in a third batch, we let
the grated garlic sit for 10 minutes
while we prepared the other
ingredients, then finally
mixed it in with the other ingredients.
So while these seem like small
adjustments to the order of operations,
the flavor differences are huge.
The citric acid in the lemon
juice speeds the conversion
of that harsh-tasting allicin to some
mellower compounds, the same ones
that are created when garlic is heated.
Soaking the garlic in lemon
juice was a bit more effective
than putting the garlic directly
in the dressing with all
of the other ingredients.
But either approach is far better than
letting the minced garlic hang out
for 10 minutes.
In that sample, the garlic
flavor was overpowering,
and it made for a pretty bad dressing.
So this is a really simple experiment.
I encourage you to try it at home.
You'd really be able to taste
the differences yourself.
Now, what does all this
have to do with pesto?
Well, you can use heat or acidity to
keep sliced basil from changing color.
Now, you can find a lot of
recipes on the internet that
suggest throwing a vitamin C tablet,
otherwise known as ascorbic acid,
into the food processor
with the other ingredients.
I have two bowls of pesto here
that I made two hours ago.
The only difference is that this one
has 1,000 milligrams of vitamin C in it.
As you can see, it's bright green,
versus the one that doesn't have any.
Now unfortunately, you can
really taste the vitamin C
and it makes the pesto
kind of unpleasantly tart,
so this isn't really a great option.
But I have a third bowl of pesto
here that I also made two hours ago.
Now as you can see, it's pretty much
the same color as the vitamin C batch.
Now, I can tell you the big
difference is that it tastes exactly
like the darkened pesto.
And that's because it's made
with the identical ingredients
as the dark sample,
with just one change.
I blanched the basil leaves in
simmering water for 20 seconds
before processing them with
the remaining ingredients.
And as I mentioned
earlier, heat deactivates
the enzymes that react
with oxygen to cause
that dark color in the first place.
And the best part is it's
completely effective.
When we ran this test and
refrigerated the pesto for a week,
it was still brilliant green.
The only trouble with this technique is
that you need to bring a pot of water
to a boil, then need to shock and
blanch the basil in a bowl of ice water.
So this method makes great sense if
you're turning a bumper crop of basil
from your garden into pesto that
you plan to freeze for many months.
But it's a lot of work for pesto
you want to toss with pasta tonight,
so I'm going to show you a simpler way
with the test kitchen's favorite pesto
recipe.